here at the largo theater messing around
uh with my really good friends of many
decades jimmy vevino
james wormworth on the tubs right there
and then of course
mike merritt here holding on down with
the base
and just a true story for many years
both at nbc
and then uh later on on turner uh the
band was always there at rehearsal
and i would get impatient if i was
waiting
for a piece of writing or a sketch to be
ready to rehearse
and so what i finally did is i found a
song that was so irritating to the
writers
that if i gave them 15 20 minutes and
the piece wasn't ready
i'd start to play this song a little
something
by the georgia satellites by the way a
group i really admire and i love this
song but the way i do it
is super annoying drove the writers
insane but got me those sketches on time
let's do it
[Music]
i get
[Music]
and keep your hands to yourself
[Music]
still your lover boy i still feel the
same way
you know she told me a story about free
milk in a cow
[Music]
keep your hands
[Music]
hello
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and keep your hand in yourself
[Music]
so
[Music]
and by then the writers had the sketch
ready to go
yeah i've wasted so many people's lives